[Music]
you're in the woods you hear the quiet
howling of a pack of wolves the rustling
tall grass in the wind to your left a
monster climbs out of the trees glowing
an unnatural shade of blue but you're
not afraid because you're the hunter not
the hunted what does scare you though is
other hunters monsters dragons and the
lunatics that hunt them it's a jungle
out there in nearly a decade of
competitive League of Legends
one role has changed more frequently
more dramatically than any other but in
every year after every rework and
despite every nerf a resilient group of
players have made it their mission to
master it this is the story of league of
legends as general and of those players
brave and bold to conquer it
jungling wasn't always a core part of
league of legends in the games earliest
days the to12 meta was more popular and
viable in a huge range of configurations
and a big reason for that is that the
jungle camps hit hard in the days before
season 1 jungle camps were unpredictable
and it was easy to miss out on
experience for the ones you did manage
but soon players began to realize that
ignoring the gold and experience offered
by jungle Dreams was inefficient and
they started to disappear into the
wilderness to hunt monsters and
champions and by the time competitive
play began to truly pick up in 2010
chun-li was seen as a standard part of
the game bill and so I'm gonna wait to
call up the lane matchup until they get
spotted by minions but unsurprisingly
both teams will be running a jungler but
that's not to say that jungling in
season one was a refined of art and
junglers like Malphite and warwick who
boasted both sustained and ganking
potential dominated in season one
gentleman I was really individually
happy where the journalists were able to
gain every Lane because trinkets were
not there yet everyone just tried to
outplay one another mechanically and was
a pretty fun ride actually by the time
season 2 came around several quality of
life changes had made jungling more
straightforward clearing camps was
easier and more champions were viable
than ever and it was in that era of
creativity and discovery that one of the
game's seminal junglers rose to
prominence I will do describe myself as
a player to someone as I was doing
season two I would say that this guy
just doesn't hold the rules he
definitely wanted to jungler his own
style and he didn't want to adapt to
what everyone else was doing whenever he
was trying something new out it would
usually go well and like a lot of other
players and teams would try the things
out and they wouldn't have as great of a
success as he did so I think that's like
the main reason why he's considered
really good
Daniel diamondprox to the chef Nick Hoff
was a pioneer in the jungle as part of
the dominant moscowfive roster he
terrorized the rest of the game's best
junglers in 2012 every jungle was really
bad
I was just a little bit better or maybe
but just better than all of them just
because everyone was thinking about
their side of the jungle like something
like there is home which is secured by
someone that no one is going to in fact
Emma but it was not true home is gonna
cover on this will they get first blood
three minutes into the game here and
exhaust onto em boy will he be able to
get away there comes flat Amir coming in
again and a nice job by diamond to pick
that first one up on to Emma and that is
something that m5 is known for the
counter jungle early in the game
diamonds he's gonna go any smites it
straightaway onto us I will dominate
first but we'll be coming down here you
can see meanwhile that blue [ __ ] across
the woods goes
for master Chi a sleazy Weezy no all by
himself while three members of Moscow
five and SK is not making any moves to
help their jungle and that's exactly
what diamondprox was talking about I can
count that jungle of my own I'd met him
to help me diamondprox developed a
reputation for picking unusual junglers
that the rest of the world underrated
he played Shyvana before she became
recognized as the terror she was and was
even able to make Evelyn work Pekka is
probably dead from this one misses the
charm flashed over the wall from diamond
that's another one seven one six and of
course he was a terror on more meta
junglers - right sir Rob diamonds going
there Joey does out does not have the
escape illusion comes there taking quite
a bit of damage
the second bomb is on time approached a
panic picking it back as well flow there
is the Valkyrie away but they are gonna
get in on two wards got some pepper
could this be first well that comes
elise in the cutes connection there is
the first they have managed to dog once
was locust in the ulti coming out from
Karthus oh a good ol tea cake there that
will take down half the damage locust
will go down and that almost certainly
will force out a free dragon diamondprox
had better pathing and better mechanics
than other junglers in season two and
managed to push the game forward with
his outstanding play but even as
diamondprox pioneered his gank heavy
creative style riot seemed unsure as to
whether they wanted a jungler in every
game gold value was not as high from
clearing the jungle in those days and
junglers often found themselves playing
more as a second support than a core
well farmed position junglers in season
two often relied on gold generation
items for income purchased lots of wards
and tried to snowball their laners since
camps were balanced around the idea that
laners would often take them for backup
CS this was by design League of Legends
is at a fundamental level based on dota
and in the early days Riot was
comfortable emulating their predecessor
and though jungling was viable in DOTA
allstars it was not a permanent part of
the game in the early days of league
Riot wanted
to be a choice not a necessity but by
season 3 jungling became more than an
afterthought it was a mixture of farming
and ganking like he would only gank if
you had a free kill or this could burn a
flesh for free take a look in the middle
though oh my gosh the damage I was there
on Alex first what actually picked up by
diamond to balance an increase to camp
difficulty riot with the first jungle
specific items in the game hunters
machete and the corresponding spirit
stone upgrades they changed leashing to
work more like it does today and decided
that going forward they would balance
the game around a111 to lane setup but
though junglers in season 3 were able to
finish builds more often fewer champions
were viable in the role powerful bursty
mid laners like Zed and re dominated the
mid lane in 2013 and sometimes ganking
the game's most central Lane was a death
sentence in season 3 if you would go mid
lane as a jungler and you'll try to gank
and mid lane with level 6 he just wants
to jangles were like only tanks kinda so
your role as that I can initiate and and
like CC for the team and then your
carries will carry the game junglers
might have been more secure with their
place in the game in 2013 but once again
they took a back seat to their carries
so it may come as no surprise that one
of the most famous controlling junglers
of all time rose to prominence in season
3 Bay bangies jung woon is among the
most decorated players in the history of
League of Legends yet his legacy will
always live in fakers shadow known
alternatively as the jungle itself and
God's right hand
bengi was known from the beginning for
his remarkable pathing vision control
and Games's and he was the glue that
held SKT together at Worlds in 2013 my
eyes have been on bengi I really like
the way he plays his jungle really
vision centric really mobility based
almost ii support on the map
it's what basically snowballs SKT sleep
whenever they get ahead they will not
lose that lead ever again because bang
is constantly warding constantly
helping ganks getting where he has to be
really quickly because of his mobility
think bengi is actually the key here for
SKT because especially compared to royal
these guys play a much longer laning
phase they will sit in lanes and try to
outs kill you and banky will go make
plays it was especially later in his
career in 2015 and 2016 that he refined
his vision control and pathing focused
style during those years SKT tried to
make a younger jungler blank work for
them with a more aggressive style
blanket cleanse this time gets off the
ultimate but thinking of slowing down
there's the arrow in Athena knows he has
to go all-in but he can't really do much
go to the first night but agility and
blankets himself another kill but in the
end in the highest pressure moments of
SK T's back-to-back World Championships
it was often bengi stable unflappable
presence that allowed his team to excel
it had to do something else but the
relevance applying for you but he gets
spoiled by banking fujihara Bank again
anyway it's with Bruce goodbye look for
the harass got hit a return and now the
double bomb forces of black sub curl
this ton of a baker not a matter if you
already have the old the other side
bangy again now the double kill the
flash shield birthday the
but look at the trade damn it just took
him maybe he'll flash but that's gonna
play and goodbye banky lands the javelin
red buff over the jungler after all SKT
fight their way back in elimination game
Becky subs back and he saves SKT now
we're going to Game five to control the
bottom side of this map shockwaves gonna
you know won't be up in time but they
don't 2,700 bang and it's a-440
what the hell just happened baekje goes
in he stops peanut from being able to
secure the baron and it's all she wrote
for this one scan Telecom t1
against the wall bang himself 300
against rocks Tigers in the series and
SKT ticket to their third world final
it's easy to overlook bengi but
alongside faker he remains the only
player to have ever secured three World
Championships and it was his style of
jungling that allowed the greatest
player of all time to shine and in stark
contrast to bangies slower controlling
play 2013 saw another huge development
in the jungle one that was about nothing
but mechanics Choi in sec in silks
legendary Lee sin kick changed
everything for junglers definitely
impactful for this game
very very low gets too full of Indians
for their records through the residence
coming out with joy
to chase that diamond the board in
kickback buy-in second piece in is so
hopefully the end you can see that your
immunity was not right for it they
covered it up so well the start of this
fight was just so key when insect comes
in behind delegate Hughes in wards back
kicks in that is so hard to execute even
though Europe tried to come when it made
really everyone sit on the rumble
ultimate they'd already lost through ad
carry and they burned all their CC
release account initiation so the rest
of Korea just chased out you know more
with jungle players have to play as a
second support now a jungler with enough
skill could carry a game the insect kick
looks commonplace in modern league but
at the time it revolutionized the jungle
and pushed the boundaries of what was
expected of the position topside looks
great wow it went so far to get the
insect on the mystic buddy shield no but
they're able to white him the log goes
down to the back vidcon he's gonna try
to assassinate it but that is way too
deep stage that is they keep him up to
he goes death there were several tweaks
to the jungle heading into 2014
including a new camp the white changes
to smite and the personal ward cap but
all together these changes added up to a
meta that finally allowed junglers to be
the carry light assassins like rengar
and kha'zix flourished in 2014 and the
world's greatest junglers learned to
sharpen their office
having vision control and ganking were
still vital but this time they were
doing it on aggressive champions that
could build and snowball a lead just
coming from clearlove everybody getting
items that they want and don't
necessarily need but they're doing the
damage with you trying to start a fight
by himself Goro again going into a 3d
one situation the sprites are going to
go right through and take down touch and
they're in the face for the win he gets
the triple kill he's going to go for the
quadric crystal gets that there's
Nicotra kill go for the new work can
they go up to off the bat so he can join
the room he wants to go
[Applause]
and well there's a reason 2014 means
many older junglers favorite season stop
more backs and they gonna get that as
well insect is actually really good and
perhaps no jungler better embodied and
dominated this meta than Samsung White's
joy dandy in queue along with the rest
of Samsung white at Worlds 2014 dandy
was the linchpin in a strategy that
revolved around and fading for vision
alongside his support Monta they kept on
that's the flash for the idol Duran we
were saying that had to happen but it's
an all in you have to get out spirit
with the nice jump to the back he could
have that reset to get out for the man
it's quite low
Dandy's trying to get the fight on as
vision in the brush now into the base
Dante goes down boxes gonna pick up
doubles their wings right off the
inhibitor turret gonna go down 26 and a
half minutes in that's why
Dandy's rengar is so legendary samsung
white would often light up the Mac and
snowball leads into early victories set
some white leaving just two men left
alive will focus in on the Nexus and
after less than 23 minutes here opening
up the victory against AHQ dandy and
mata pushed the jungle support synergy
to a whole new level and though he never
again saw the success he enjoyed in 2014
during that year of assassinations and
fast paced play few Shawn quite as
bright effort gets caught by Emperor on
the outside they do take out Mata very
early everyone extremely grouped up
right now looper getting in there with
the AoE it's getting scary and dandy
coming in there's a kill for looper
dandy comes in to try to get the reset
another kill for infants well there's
dandy with another he's got the double
and shy will just make sure he doesn't
take too much damage here in the top
lane so swim
there's a cocoon Omata hits him with the
death sentence it pulls him right out of
that safeguard it's dodging those Spears
Samson chasing they could turn onto
Barrett right now they're not doing it
though dandy jason says execute our bad
life by the end of 2014
junglers were accustomed to the constant
changes to their position but that
offseason saw perhaps the biggest shift
of any year riot didn't just change
items they didn't just adjust certain
camps they threw out the entire map 2015
summoners rift redesigned pushed
league's visual design into the modern
era but the gameplay changes that
accompany the redesign hit the jungle
the hardest red and blue buff remained
largely unchanged and there were still
wolves on the map but every other camp
was completely changed for starters
wraiths became Raptors the white became
Grom and the golems became the crog's
which in late 2016 were changed into the
Russian nesting doll clear time
eviscerating nightmare that they are
today
oh no the crux now died on Jarvan to the
crog's in the 2017 Kasparov and I still
private message in one M Street
streaming that's a real care the crowds
this is why and that was just the camp's
in the river things weren't done
changing ride added the peaceful rift
Scuttler a crab that roamed the river to
provide gold and vision to whoever
killed it they changed dragon from an
objective that gave the team flat gold
to a new stacking buff they changed
Baron buff from a stat buff to a buff to
nearby minions I just really liked the
way Baron and dragon have been changed
to the way that dragon buffs work right
now they put a time around the game
fifth dragon buff is really important I
like what Baron brings in terms of
staging so now when I'm not I cannot be
useless as a support in mid game I can
just walk to that Lane buff those creeps
and become my own split pusher basically
the jungle as we knew it was turned
upside down and by the end of 2015
riot added the rift Herald
crumbs dies here oh my god oh my god a
new neutral objective that provided a
buff to whoever claimed it
the rift Herald was envisioned as a way
to combat the balance of early
objectives towards the bottom of the map
and would go through several reworks
over the years because that is a rift
herald in the middle of fanatics face at
20 minutes Khan can cut through these
towers in an instant fnatic are out of
options they got one last chance one
opportunity to try to see the fight but
there is nothing in their wheelhouse
there is nothing in the toolkit all they
see as fascist in front of them this
game is the story of Khan farming it up
and Brigida
but all told the rift Herald or Shelly
as she's been affectionately nicknamed
changed the way every team thinks about
objectives whoever doesn't control that
is actually giving up on something if
you stay safe and farm under Tower
that's an objective you've just lost
mangle this one is give burly dudes who
win top a thing that lets them show cool
I win this is what you better stop me
from getting in 2015 and 16 a new wave
of junglers made their names on the new
map new junglers like Han peanut Wang ho
peanut first made a name for himself
ranking up on the Korean solo queue
ladder but he got his first shot at
greatness when he joined the rocks
Tigers in 2016 peanut was a charismatic
aggressive young player whose big
personality fit in well with the
over-the-top Tigers but more importantly
his aggressive jungle style was exactly
the shot in the arm the Tigers needed
this group of players that have either
retired or been rejected by
big sponsor no big team house it's not
necessary because they are going to lck
summer and they are going to get a
spotted world to get married as brunch
Tigers taken gg
it's about time peanut took 2014's
blueprint for carry junglers and
combined it with his brashness to become
an absolute terror peanut didn't just
kill you in 2016 he made you feel it the
reengage that gorilla means nothing
because suddenly peanut is here on the
Olaf a flash force and out of my love
but he is still chasing on the Deaf
who's nearly out of HP the chase on ray
first blood - for PETA it might be a
third and the reengage for koro1 can he
do much of anything also worth noting is
sort of sort of par for the course is
self did he cried a little for here's
the jump in a few more attacks will do
it and that's first that was beautiful
now he has to get really scared and he
also has to tell to to worry out a
little bit oh there is rush there it is
it's peanut a lot of damage don't forget
and HP on bengi to repel the chase come
for attack the flash and though he's
since matured as a player peanut will
always be known for his crazy invades
his total fearlessness on carrots and
for the reckless abandon that gave us
some of the greatest league series of
all time
the other big change that came with
2015's map redesign was a rework for
jungle items now hunter's machete would
transform into one of four items giving
a range of bonuses skirmishers Sabre
gave smite a buff to Dueling stalkers
blade gave smite a slow ranger's
trailblazer gave smite and AoE on jungle
monsters and poachers knife gave you
bonuses for killing camps in the enemy
jungle those upgrades have gone through
some iterations like the coming and
going of trackers knife the jungle
warding item but riot seemed generally
happy with that structure however the
enchantments to jungle items have
consistently wreaked havoc on the game's
balance cinderhulk fundamentally warped
the nature of tanks in spring 2015
briefly turning sejuani into an
unkillable raid boss and totally
changing the jungle meta to focus on
tanks hello hidden right just glory
doesn't really says Wadi ultimate if TSM
can make it through this they got it but
Clarke died is locking them down
garrison on the outside he gets walked
in with the position reverser
how is TSM still alive in this one they
are doing everything they can but cloud
9 close
the door on that fight runeglaive was
such a disaster in 2015 that mid laners
took smite just to prioritize it over
all other items before it was hotfix
away from yours it just cost himself the
life while growth goes out boomerang
goes across trueshot barrage for the
finish so many things that can come
across to kill you ninja and devours
various versions have existed for years
in a constant state of either completely
changing the game or being totally
unpickable Riot has to walk a fine line
with these enchantments fundamentally
their goal is to allow every class of
jungler a way to clear their camps camps
that have been steadily buffed since the
games early days and now are basically
unkillable early without jungle items
but making them too powerful can lead
laners to take smite in order to infuse
effects designed to kill jungle creeps
with quite a bit more HP than champions
quadric help just like that the Orianna
getting secured it up yes he can
power of evil rune glaive Orianna
getting a pentakill in the first game
added unity console of midway through
2016 riot took a new approach to dragons
adding elemental dragons to the rift
that each provide a different bonus you
should see teams contesting these much
more because these dragons are all more
powerful than the dragons you saw last
year and contrary to popular belief
every single dragon is actually very
strong and I actually think they're very
close in power they're just strong in
different parts of the game they also
added the elder dragon which took the
game ending place of the old fifth
dragon and at the end of 2016
riot decided to make another big change
introducing plants to the summoners rift
the blast cone Squires bloom and honey
fruit were another attempt by riot to
implement some controlled orangey to the
game and they changed map options for
all roles but perhaps most strongly
affected junglers they're slowed for
like 35% when you take those when you
eat those so ill there will be fights
around the river all the time so I don't
believe my honey for you as well I
really just think the blast code is kind
of strange and not necessarily what I
expected when I think of I'm gonna be
the jungler and as a juggler my role in
this game is to use the blast cone to
elevate me to new heights over the wall
to steal his dragon oh this seems really
really 2017 s jungle meta focused on
tanky initiators but this time it wasn't
a young gun who dominated the Year
rather it saw the resurgence of one of
the game's most veteran players
ambition wasn't always a jungler he
switched the position for mid in one of
the most successful role swaps ever and
after years of struggling to put his
mark on the professional scene ambition
triumphed in 2017 she's come out let's
go for another tower dive boys she ain't
got the backup of Fundy failure Knowles
if it's not good enough and busy gets
one back at w/e they bit enough older
they can shoot the world's met a favored
tanky initiators right in ambitions
wheelhouse Oh
body slam was out of control but
delivered underneath the tart ambition
more than happy to go against this and
after searching for a big win for years
he's Shawn on the game's biggest stage
let's get those up the silicone out
first right away but tonight's forward
gets away from akka get through netted
crowd gets up that killed the mid-late 5
to 0 in the game it's not too much so
the Hulkster down here comes to read and
get once again for ambition wants to add
the damage
Gilbert from the rest of the beads FTTH
if it's done the rule against it blow
gets pushed back and gonna stay alive
another reagent giant South and approve
it and he blows up bang that's a lot
preserve the Chasen is there and they're
gonna get rid of the botlane entirely
there's no caries left for SKT that
changed to be had Samsung Galaxy now
will control of the river that signals
the end of the SKT dynasty there are no
turrets it is 5 vs 3 hoody do you have
what it takes to win the game
on the nexus the upset is complete as
the Celts come through the SKT dynasty
[Applause]
Samsung Galaxy their 2017 champions
[Applause]
in summer 2018 riot made another drastic
change to the game one that changed bot
lane pics it was intended to give teams
the chance to play champions beyond
marksmen in the position but the
reverberations reached all the way to
the jungle where a new style took off
funneling funnel cops saw teams pair
either a mid lane or jungle support with
the hyper carry bags on the desk I need
one I got a knock up - let's see the
Baron doing all the work for him first
picking up a killing spree on the mundo
Baron still up for grabs
double kill down goes amazing and
Jacques are gonna get cleaned off the
map that's a triple kill for Perks make
that a Quadra and pick up the Baron to
boot and push all the farm from both the
Lane and the jungle onto one champion
the win condition for it is basically
it's it's a really it's obviously has to
be a really broken combo between this
kind of like support and jungle mid lane
or whatever so you see a lot of like
nunu Karthus which is kind of like
cheese but the original was like tech
Master Yi bizarre compositions like
tarik Master Yi dominated the meta for a
portion of the summer to me the only
reason he'd first picked the new do is
take the collar and we're gonna get it
right away curtis holy crap there is no
secret as to what's going on now and
even as riot made the strategy less
effective some teams like europe's g2
continued to employ it throughout the
year but i also have a message for the
Riot Games please just change the gold
fueling strats i don't need to play
bromb again i love the fact that
sometimes you can go for the gold
funeral link instead of normal jungle I
think it's fun maybe my team is just not
being nice and they are just douchebags
and they're just putting me on braum
every game maybe it's because of my team
I don't know for better or for worse
final compositions dramatically warped
the way jungle was played for much of
the year
but by the end of the year funnel had
fallen out of favor funnel getting
nerfed basically if you're funneling and
you have a hunter's item you're going to
gain a lot less gold that you can still
choose to funnel and halves my end not
by machete which is probably gonna be
the next step of that thing you just
don't gain machete XP which will be a
pretty substantial North Yorks begin but
that just might be what happens either
way a small morph to funneling funneling
less common is I think happy for almost
every new players League of Legends and
at Worlds in a year that saw Korea
struggle internationally junglers like
Brock's ax and Ning stepped in to fill
the void they're gonna try for another
one this one body stem stops the queue
here come bow in as well to be one
Broxson may have been up more that he
can shoot a health first wedding down
League of Legends has almost always been
a game defined by its five roles and
over the years every position has seen
its fair share of change but no position
has demanded as much flexibility from
its players as the jungle no role has
required players to play every class of
champion sometimes at the same time no
role has required the same amount of map
awareness or decision big dam is the
type in for nocturnal where's the flash
gonna be the chasing
fifty/fifty made alive the jungle is
leagues hardest role and the players
who've mastered it have etched their
names into the history of esports
forever
they've played a bit are kind of a bit
weight it's one side you can be chilly
top second that looks great wow it went
so far to get the insect on the mystic
bunny shield no but they're able to
disappoint him the long goes down in the
back and Connie's gonna try to
assassinate it but that is way too deep
stages ideas they keep him up so he goes
death they've adapted he's gonna get
caught by those cuddly teddy he's slow
here comes peanut in underneath the
turret doesn't matter if he's exhausted
still comes up with a kill and they've
conquered
hello there is the Valkyrie away but
they are gonna get in on two worlds got
some pepper could this be first well
that comes Elise in the cutes collection
and there is the first word from these
in blue shockwaves get all the damage
they need trying to start a fight by
himself Koro again going into a 3d one
situation the sprites are gonna go right
through and take down touch and they're
in the base for the win he gets the
triple kill he's gonna go for the
quadric crystal gets out there's the
goal to kill before held a newborn can
they go up talked about though he's
joining the room he was
PETA has guardian angel maybe he plays
frontline how much can they really get
again it's got his Blake in his sights
Baker's low how much more can they get
this coming
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button